I'm Amanda and I live yoga this is your
at-home yoga balance workout so hey guys
we've got a special workout for you
today this is a yoga balance workout but
for everyone out there who sits behind a
desk
maybe sits behind the wheel of a bus or
something like that if you spend a lot
of time sitting down you're spending a
lot of time compressing the lower back
here yeah walk me through this Amanda so
we'll start at the top of our mat feet
hip-width distance apart we're gonna
take our hands down to these weights now
you could use blocks could meet these
books whatever whatever you have
accessible it's gonna kind of bring the
floor up to you until bring the hands
down to the tops of the weights take the
right leg back behind you stretch that
heel back so you get linked through the
hamstring pull the navel up and in chest
is reaching forward so you have a long
spine again incorporating the length of
the spine so no compression in the
spinal joints you're gonna exhale soften
your left knee as you bring your right
knee into your chest reach it back up no
again
the fingertips can be down to the mat
but if you want to play with balance
here
here chest exhale bring the in to chest
and reach it back out and stretch it out
you can even walk the fingertips down
stretching out that left leg
slowly stepping back for high lunge
arms come on start just straighten and
bend that leg again balance and strength
so for balance if you needed to bring
that back foot down and just bend that
front leg for balance absolutely but if
you're playing with it you know try to
stay into that lunge pose you're
strengthening that left leg bring your
arms out to either side as you reach
your chest or it arms out like an
airplane pull the navel up and in so now
you're almost entirely on this front leg
lift up that back leg set it down and
again if you need to bring the hands
down hands come down okay open up to the
warrior two straighten the front leg I'm
going to read for into a sign bow pose
here so the hand can come down to the
shin and reach up to the sky or if it
can come down to the outside of the mat
again you're stretching through your
inner inner groin and hips but you're
also strengthening the legs here and
strengthening the core back to your
warrior two hands down to the mat step
back to plank
and lower through your vinyasa the reset
jump to the front not you come all the
way up to standing
hands down to the weights and take your
right leg far behind you now bring the
hip down towards the mat so you're
closing off that right hip yeah
and now lift your inner right thigh up
towards the sky yeah and reach your heel
back let's see if you can reach your
chest or sink it a long line of energy
nice you start to soften your left knee
as you bring your right knee into your
chest
exhale around reach it back up so now
you're incorporating core bring me into
chest reach it back up one more cut like
that and knee into chest reach it back
out step back to a high lunge arms come
up
searches straighten and Bend that top
leg that front leg open inhale straight
at seven one more time inhale straighten
Excel bench we're gonna bring our hands
to fry our chest you're gonna start to
lean forward now to take that right leg
officer Griffis let's hold it here take
your time as you step back with high
lunge arms up and open up that warrior
two
straighten out your front leg now reach
that right arm forward forward and Forge
down to your shin so see if you can
bring your left knee up towards your
face so engage your left or your left
quads
yeah and open the chest up to the sky
there you go
bring it back to warrior two
bring the hands down to the mat step
back as you lower through your vinyasa
sit lower to each other on a porch
facing dog downward-facing soft the
knees lift a hands jump herself come all
the way up and then you do it on your
left side okay guys so to recap this
balance centric yoga workout we started
off with the warrior three stepped into
the high lunge then open to a warrior
two go to the triangle pose lowered
through the vinyasa chaturanga to the
Cobra to the downward facing dog and
then you repeat this on the other side
I mean I gotta say this is again very
balanced centric as I mentioned but all
those things I talked about with the
lower back getting here really come into
play if you spend a lot of time sitting
behind the desk you know things like
that these are muscles you don't use I
mean most people don't use these muscles
thank you for taking the time to run us
through them and make sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any other
fighting weight episodes